what soul food podcast with Felipe
Esparza and Rodrigo Torres yet people
were back and I was so full podcast um
last week we have Fred Stoller I
downloaded that book
hey Larry yeah Elliott Larry a new
Kindle hilarious you get to heaven have
a chance to get that Fred stolle book
it totally talks about in depth about
those three those comedian Dylan young
comedian show one of them dies of AIDS
damn one of them gets mucked get stupid
suicide one of the compass test for to
become successful and one just quit
stallin theater the real people mad um
David Spade and Rob Schneider blew up
huh oh hell yeah they were enormous
here's a detail bro but the
personalities how they walked into the
room all badass or not bad ass off since
the beginning yeah man
first older man mad what a mess why the
heart of a book tell us part of the book
where everybody getting Rick at night
from that HBO special right know that no
comedy central's in the beginning of
comedy that's right so they were showing
like not a lot of comedy but only that
HBO special he said that her Mexican
valet guy recognized them and he was
running running to go get another car
and Fred chase tumbrils who asked him
how he do holy tell Reggie will be saved
by skinny ass with a leather jacket hey
compadre how did I do oh you did
alrighty let the other girl the blond
guy [ __ ] feedback down
yeah manager a giggity man in-depth and
there because then one thing like when
you know comedians we got what to chat
here was so much a chat one so fool and
now he's back and you know like you say
the group of friends you have just say
when you take your locals when you're
doing you the Comedy Jam right a local
coming again how many other comedians at
your level did it at that that year like
young to me that that year um
and then the final rumor they did other
renditions over there at the other
studios were was different but a lot of
big comedians to load on your shoulder a
little bit on there
Luke tours on there who else Carlos
Oscar did at that time with you yeah and
then not not on my show who let no show
though it was Luke Torres that's only
when I can remember dude right now rule
at Mira no diamond ridden to that show
so on the book it breaks down just
saying you did Alan with these other
comics and he really he really tells
that where they all went and what what
kind of Fame they got one of them
brought a show like just different type
of pain man like a Rob Schneider come
right away Lord Michael wanted to meet
him right and they want him to go to New
York he goes he'll not go New York I got
a show at the San Diego comedy for 75
bucks I can't let that go for to go do
that gig instead dog really and he was
yeah he said he was driving to the gig
thing and I just made the worst mistake
of my life i banned it but he but um
Lord Michael thought that was cool that
he was gonna do that gig so on the next
day um he told managers you know [ __ ]
that you thought I put a fly me out
there
oh damn my Tampa yeah oh sorry Roberto
Roberto I'm actually like I'm Sarah Pete
Tom only five eight I mean it worked out
it did forgot he said that later on and
his story Rob Schneider says that Lord
Michael he was the only comedian their
Lord Michael flew out oh damn but then
he got in oh [ __ ] yeah
another comedian you know during the
black comedian Warren Thomas I think
that his name
Warren Hutchinson LaGuerta [ __ ] Sena
origin of the producer for the DL
Hughley show the Warren Thomas he was a
guy who ripped like he's to riff he held
it like that's when he first order Kitty
broke it down broke
first Stoller broke down the five
comedian there on that show the way life
really is like I work with a lot of
people and it's your ally a lot of
people think that Fame it is going to
come to you but it's also you can have a
certain type of maturity man to be
famous or to be in that
level of Fame where people are calling
you because if you're lame you know
you're me you don't your phone call you
never get favorite it should be a lot of
years to get this far
alright why because I'm not a good
businessman back then I was [ __ ] up
so they told this guy to wait she would
still nor the last black comedian on the
ferry my life was um Eddie Murphy
oh yeah every 35 years so they wanted
this guy you wanna meet him because he
was sharp
he was really quick you know he was
quick he forgot tired of waiting in the
office while he left really but I heard
that Lord Michael and notorious for
making food wait and is that just to see
if they'd last just the other patients
or something you know you have long said
long shoots they want to tell you I
oh damn stuff we just took off he passed
a psychological part they do get it
daughter but literally year later to
give it a Chris Rock
oh damn like that I got up dude
I remember heard that once over got no
additional or Michael whatsoever well
remember that one story that we heard I
forgot her we heard it from but it was a
Charles Barney
Charles Barden and he was in line with
Eddie Murphy Murphy he didn't know how
to read or write or something later
April
yeah but he's funny as [ __ ] best for our
narrowed I selected whatever he was well
I think he couldn't read it right yeah
so um yeah I magically ass dude he can't
read or write when you get to the top so
they gotta give it to Eddie Murphy know
how to read right anybody could act
because I met a guy that working in a
movie with me David Payne or David Poe
ball he plays Richie a prio on Italian
for Joe Diaz got that who I'd tell you
guys are doing the deported here he got
high man he told me that he was a coach
for Charles Burnett
he coached him on DC cab in acting and
he coach Eddie Murphy and Trading Places
oh yeah me so he's at old school on that
old school kinda seems out the whole
time in the background looking like Al
Pacino's [ __ ] brother that's it
so they had Matt oh ji-hun us yeah so so
that was the what happened man
- a lot of chameleons you know even a
lot of comedians I came up with like
they don't know how to return phone
calls or tomorrow the big day but
they're gonna get [ __ ] up the night
before no name yeah bro I got [ __ ] up
with each other or take me bro Bethany
was a limousine driver yeah man you're
like realness it's so good it's a [ __ ]
she gave you they roll anything for poor
people done yeah man so it's a good book
mm oh it's like honey pages five now
I've read a little passage good how many
pictures are short hordes every games
short chapel feathers 80 Kendall pages
that's a book this good man he breaks it
down bro like a long time to think about
all man here's decades that were worried
about his set dawg the wholesale I'm
reading to show up a day early to the
show to go over your set that food shows
over his wardrobe already does right
heroine holding ejaculate David Spade
Caesar uh fresh donors here with all is
cold right oh man we're gonna do an
upper game now I'm gonna kill it with a
wardrobe I'll bag it on tomorrow hard ah
dude single shoulder with wardrobe dog
and then I'm has you know like some
comedians you know Richard they got to
do it there stat before they perform a
night before I get there doing a TV show
fresh stolen shows up and all together
that he bombed hated that more funcly'
young comic you were doing it forever
ah dude hey that was some hardcore [ __ ]
so he [ __ ] hit that guy he like give
a horse intro ever he had a horrible set
shot I said what a cubicle dozer you're
gonna go through a ghost jokes oh my god
in the club they'll prepping the night
before his shed got aired though right
okay
you know we've seen that that in Detroit
room when it goes up our hairstyle it's
not a joke a joke that goes up into the
Jota works ever
where didn't work that night didn't work
in Boston yeah mango this joke has been
proved on the road for years except
tonight and then we're tonight [ __ ]
well anyways bye that's a book if you
don't want to get it get it not go get
I'll just talk about every week what's
the title five minutes to kill my friend
Stella started Sean Bronson oh [ __ ]
what's up like what's up for upcoming
shows tonight Cinco de Mayo Colusa
casino with Regina Torres and larry
bubble brown mur mur me 18 through 20
first I'll be at the Tempe improv with
Rosie go tourists Chris Doering he's
back hey Brown and tagging along
- looking for a bit another victim
Marshall Rizzo will be there for the
Thursday show and a Sunday show and
maybe the Saturday night later buddy how
are ya hey Roger yeah baby good touch he
asked over here Don Bora May 25th 2008
Irvine improv Irvine improv Orange
County we have no idea it's gonna be
there but I'll be there but Raja will be
there
Tommy hey she'll be there how cool who
better get up and I got Duy on the way
home rascal - who knows him in Nebraska
nobody I mean man y'all gonna come
saying that Jews first to afford
Arlington Texas at the Arlington improv
that's right people check on Filippo's
Worldcon slashed or four other dates and
the rest of the year shoutouts okay let
me put on my glasses for this [ __ ] he
still got the Amazon portal we got the
Amazon porter on Philippa's world.com
happy people if you want to shop on
Amazon just go to our web page we get 50
cents every time you buy something
start your search at our page go to
Philippa worldcom and then go to Amazon
don't use Google remote just load up a
little world.com and then include a
little Amazon window just buy whatever
you want
anything anything okay shoutouts it's
been a while stand we give an out shout
out to these people for people love
shout out we like to hear their name out
there even know if it's in bad taste you
want it okay representing they want to
be famous
hell yeah they want a piece of the
action right shout out to that woman
that listened to me in the mornings
right on Iowa what's your name I don't
know your name you know who you are you
know who you are you call in every time
and I guess what I'm coming to Des
Moines Iowa at the end of July that's
right
we're coming back normal it'll be bill
Rodrigo and somebody I was calling a
demur in Des Moines or watch out hey
buddy
Des Moines funny bone yeah when I saw
when I was a kid bro I learned all the
capital of the United States and Des
Moines is the capital of Iowa but I used
to pronounce it Des Moines cool your
geographical genius does the marina's
bro it comes from somewhere you don't
know wine is violated
that's home a slip knot right there in
the capital man but I come over there
man I didn't remember the owner's wife
had just died owners husband Kristin
peace he Jedediah bro and he wanted to
do that was booked in the club by
himself with no Booker like that he was
managing and he was running the place
and his wife was hardly ever there
probably he was booking everybody booked
this food about use a computer he wrote
everything on paper old school old
school analog so that's who died there
was nothing to be told no record of
nothing who died was covered over
nothing
what had to scramble for everything but
luckily I have some comics that knew the
guy they stepped in and they helped her
you know like some comic and then I got
booked on a Sunday
TJ Billy was it the week now when you're
doing the Last Comic Standing talked at
Oprah he was there headlining the whole
week bro that's what you never see I put
headline anywhere no more
headlining boom I showed up for one
night on a Sunday that fool in the back
laughing he was taking those a bald
chick bro
tight and I'll skinny girl here comes
with a bald cutie and she puts on a hat
is on but now man she was with you bald
but she was holding other stache bro oh
really laughing giggling sit and teach a
middle man you wanna hit some hash in
Des Moines where I have nothing to smoke
of course I do
tell ya how does the one I hate Oh a
little pee to take with me say the
reason they host a hosted our love man
that's what's up dick went back to the
room I felt good
I like Sunday melon nothing to do oh
damn bro it's at the Lord's Day Des
Moines Des Moines Plaza
alright shout-out to everyone I'm who
reviewed on iTunes
King to 3:09
El Brujo the little line 86 underscore
out there delivering people's build he's
a mailman little like ki shaadi shuttle
to [ __ ] zero 207 ng ng through 207 zoom
watt oh what a name but be ugly
sergeant lunatic who lives with jiggle
impersonations alright sergeant Harris
Thank You Man
sergeant lunatic I appreciate that when
I read a service huh
he's an officer of the law who try to do
that [ __ ] such a lunatic alla Norma the
MP Chuck key b & e dot sts you know for
the name is the [ __ ] projects bro
chunky 4v any cord straight up a damn
said kilvo to was listener promised
brother course project the all the right
then there are my life for me it's this
will have a gangbanger named I thought
about keeping it real ratio cheaper ova
me button wave oh man balloon wave
Estrada bro strata courts
and that's order by Soto Street and and
Soto Street and then and by the [ __ ]
Sears role of project on the other side
of the temporary you forget that the
center of [ __ ] housing project in Los
Angeles huh you forget all you know is
what all you know is the watchtower the
Christian guardians to forget that um
there's also instrudtor cords Ramona
Gardens and that's where that's from one
of gardens and then there's a the other
clean won the tournament now why
Brentwood bro why why we would throw
there I was telling why burn wood
projects an apartment calm down but
their projects that you have the
neighborhood that's what wasn't it grew
up man from how do you know the name of
all these project I grew up in the
projects in all of those all of it well
rivals like I live in Pico Gardens
projects and we didn't get along with
people inside to go Guardian projects
like Riley will cut those two
playgrounds
I live in first playground and they
lived on second playground we had the
better pillar and playground first
playground first plague on ours was
shitty
we have multi bars we had to wait to so
much we're still a car or knock them all
down said monkey bars old school old
school I'm old school bro
together of old school monkey bars I'll
watching an old ass movie last night bro
Oh Agni
someone was out when I was a little kid
bro Dustin Hoffman Meryl Streep Kramer
vs Kramer and what's that about it I
don't know my buddies in for the portal
versus Kraemer
number versus cover like a sword fight
on Sarla starring Paris Porsche lien bro
and John Holmes and uh making her debut
that's 16 years old Traci Lords and I'm
weak god damned I remember sorry Ron
Jeremy bro with his Chancellor like who
[ __ ] step on an ant farm bro doctor
couple does comedy now right Rose what
yeah he was doing stand-up comedy's and
people doing porn and he's never been
funny the porn is a comedy though I read
his autobiography already halfway
through and I guess got tired of it bro
it was too much
cheerleading bro he like a biggest
beggar he's a tireless fool around bro
like old Ashley you know that old-ass
shoes was worn every money and they got
nothing to do with his um his
nationality
I got ahead it was a heritage Egypt or
cheap [ __ ] bro
so chief my favorite part of the book of
my ron jeremy is with Rodney Dangerfield
fighting gets tired of his dad get out
of here
he gets up and he makes him pay for
everybody's food at that restaurant cuz
he needed that cheap yeah listen running
a [ __ ] pay for everything you
[ __ ]
and he never did drugs around them he
did want to build a side chicks there I
just on the side chillin ever like I
don't for a minute I'm hanging out
somewhere and I'm getting [ __ ] up
there was bad ass over the hill porn
star next to me and he's just standing
there and he has no drugs but he picking
up bottle caps you know to save them and
make money from how I have someone broke
get him by the throat and put him on the
floor and went to go dump on his head on
a dam a german horny when i mouths open
bro
yes i will see the employers open up god
damn done program fooled us yeah
[ __ ]
Ronnie danger for made him pay I'm
saying you know the poor boy is it
should be called me me me because I
heard the [ __ ]
made out of famous people I cheerleader
with them and he said he would doing
stand-up comedy I would story sets with
Kennison well I never the [ __ ] where is
this documented and a tactic and I seen
at what time I J
short laugh actually at the improv this
is the biggest joke he did he put on his
pants and then he started playing the
piano his ass then he goes you guys ever
heard of you ever heard of moons over
Miami
it moves over the piano keys 1 1 & 1
that's over 50 girls just pull out the
big put a puppet on them or something
hat some sunglasses we saw that with
however worse as Diego at 13 we have
snuck into the san diego street scene -
that's how we do it social distortions
we hate cause you're just after their
food remember you want to hop over the
fence I'm like I'm out it's like five
fools showed up to cross the border Raji
goes there posting fools day I'm like
[ __ ] trust my back they don't teach hey
pay though who paid the boils I gotta
hop over the borders like what we
talking about Richard King because I he
was there dog
oh no we're talking about wound to the
street scene in San Diego to go check
out some bands because at that time cake
was Phillipe it was one of the biggest
fan he was only other fully to love cake
and had a new album [ __ ] comfort
Eagle so let's go down there dog it's
going to roll over dog so that's what I
drove back off [ __ ] paranoid remember
so I could even have I almost had to
pull over and a cop was behind me it's
HP oh my god was crazy but anyway so we
wouldn't have white car in the central
dog down from London tuna Bay as she
went all the way to Sacramento with that
we're not only gone we're literally but
we went to the street scene we do have
ticket it was like 45 bucks to get in
dog so these all and these were all
right we're gonna sneak in dog so we're
all looking for gaps and really have the
money huh [ __ ] now well I think we
probably would have put together the
money before then I woke up to that and
um so I just initiated a dog I hopped
the fence in this goddamn dog come down
full house like but I really am Silent
Bob what the [ __ ] come on let's go dog
take it over
[ __ ] yeah yeah and he's full got in
there later I don't know how you guys
got in there - with all the way around
bro that thinking part of a part or the
gate where the gate was lifted he went
under
okay I mean I'm finna get here me and
many walked in man I we're working there
huh khatoun like I picked up some yellow
tape and I did walk you with a bro yeah
I just got in there after we'll be back
here and then I come on I'm in there bro
for the ladder broke ha ha ha look a
maintenance guys look brick I had the
long hair brother look up a [ __ ]
roadie bro yeah I wasn't barely starting
dog but yeah you guys got anything that
are watching we see wise every
scratching his crotch or so he's wearing
sweat well when I went and a [ __ ] off
shirt nobody knew him then I said oh
[ __ ] tougher Jeremy summer Billy goes
yeah but I post a food next to his
Valley Brook Valley on him bro I
remember - yeah brief story about what
he looked like when he look like a fat
ass beaver dog I didn't get to see you
though so on the way home man we don't
know what to do live it up but we had a
friend
um days to sing for a bad name Soto I
went to her house how the squirrel does
we take Tommy that they know how just
hurt huh yeah just heard that's why we
just called you up hey we're coming over
that's busted ugly little ass pipe it
came on a keychain dog just go like 411
momma's people is bad and she had a
little daughter that was three there was
just a mini version of her gonna kill
that song was she in the pond I wish she
used to [ __ ] at the hop we pointed
out
she used to sing for the bad so - one of
the singers and she's just saying when
she tripping elephant she just did great
man but boss you're the party animal
heard she was a diva - Ana D but she got
kicked out of the some other bad for
being a diva
everyone will reward evil they have a
writer dog wardrobe well first our trip
and how people get when they're in a
band man it's a regular band well not
this band we're gonna make it dog I'm
gonna make it if you try
all right so jet ron jeremy storie
more shutouts Chucky B&E here wall to
was listed from historic old projects he
didn't leave a zip code nine zero two
three go find a man hey ready G out
there listening while he's landscaping
cutting grass [ __ ] three 13.1
dot three crashing who said the shows
everything they expected and more
alright brown glad we met your
expectations thank you
laws XIII one oh listening in the City
of Compton the cpt Rudy listening
Chicago he and his friends all come out
to our live shows last summer thank you
for coming out to our live show that
summer and possibly our greatest review
from E gears Oh who said or anything in
the hustle and bustle of life that your
mom forget to teach you how to be like
II know if you grew up thinking Taco
Bell counts as real Mexican let your new
Big Brothers Felipe Rodrigo teach you
how not to look like a punk Phillippi
grew up in Los Angeles
East LA for you noobs listening to the
Spartans will help you learn how to look
and sound like a true chief condom when
I learn a bundle of dough years where to
find the best baked goods in LA
Greenwood and Flor de Jalisco all I land
in full lighting like he likes going to
for the Jalisco shut up to the my man
from el florida Jalisco he just got
another new heart he just came out the
hospital he's a survivor
damn keep that blood pumping homie
goddamn broke start eating vegetarian
bro
[ __ ] it to be doing good bro hope you're
doing well you can't help your grandma
I'll leave your dog blood and blood out
and everything you want to know about
Willie Barcena
this podcast has heart you'll be using
on Ellen and no mom and Wade and of
course war soul food don't forget yeah
man
so don't be scared homie just download
and subscribe
spoken like a true prodigy so we will
listen to a hardcore huh
a some closer like dude it's [ __ ]
awesome done in [ __ ] info you have
people who walk up to your brother I
just want to go ah dude you be surprised
for when I went to uh so I'll give you a
hard left Universal Studios there was a
fool from Oxnard dog [ __ ] made a big
old thing so let me get everybody a
water it's hot hey oh my god
York University oh yeah the tour or no
not to the [ __ ] Park the park
yeah it's Universal Studios I did to win
uh two weeks ago I went last week we're
gonna go on Sunday but if I [ __ ] just
too much we were Saturday I love you
it's a dude you know you guys do the
walking did I put the last time ah
pretty I like it's [ __ ] badass huh hey
bull how about the Harry Potter right
dog Oh too fat to get on it bro hahaha
they say follow your lies are gonna be
trying to like make you the hero what
the [ __ ] I could get on it this wasn't a
Saha dude they want to [ __ ] about to be
like a little boss hold on ah [ __ ]
cool it's hotter clothes could I'm sworn
also you really tried oh I see the mean
bun bun is on that start drinking on a
dog is like reapplying part of my
stature I got my love tourists or
something on full I got it they were all
happy they were all excited that she
like remember remember okay bro
Oh jokes - clicks ha ha ha ha no click
you wanted another one I did get low
click I got them for gonna move me to a
fatter ride right where I could fit in
now I'm opposed to to be a dog ha ha ha
let me watch Tahu they took a yard and I
said what every man other to give it to
a world I could fit in a lot happy who
got what our book what to this door
that's by the exit and there's a regular
chair for the rider but you could sample
so they told me spin on that [ __ ] other
what they ladies electric chair right
here pull the lever I put it on bro
nothing bro
I don't want to close well was it did
check well you know what other big
people I seen one little short balls a
little butter balls on there it just
how's Chris door saying you're all torso
brown they say about what a gold book I
want em barren bro
ah you kind of walk like my little baby
talk to bachlin the manager go on there
by yourself
no they want to get on but Allah Dara T
but I saw like I saw the guy team Philly
in line
grab a bunch of fat people and took them
to the side and I'm thinking okay what's
going on here special right yeah when
they got my I did to me Oscar ride
brother we're about to go we're in a
conveyor belt and I keep it on I
wouldn't lie forever
oh yeah my goes to those who get on
Harry Potter again ah dude Harry
Potter's how you gonna do that I don't
know cut my legs I don't know I guess I
was talking to her to do yoga or
something
I think it's Koleos is done now my
favorite ride was a mummy Oh also next
one I say that's a badass ride and I
expecting that you take off like that
aw dude it [ __ ] you up and how about
the last one when it goes in Reverse
real quick and that's it though let's go
back to Faso dog I was telling Isaac
male the lights on this show this Robbie
sucky because law yeah of course dude
but yeah I like the Simpsons right cool
if it feels good you know what the
Simpsons Ride used to be right a long
time ago on waffle The Simpsons writing
universes toriel used to be the et right
really dude no oh [ __ ] uh the mummy was
et since they'll just be back to the
future that's a good future oh damn okay
yeah I never I never gonna eat you right
yeah so Inside Out Boy Ichiro was a best
really enough bison I've never got on it
you rent a bicycle and then you when
when they jump over the cars your job
the wind they can pick up the wind
hitting you and they feel like you're
going over the cars too and the the dice
man said yeah extra testicle right like
to go to uterus to the rotor little care
bro my daddy had a good job bro where
who the union job
his name was man you
I got a manual I don't know why put had
a fake ID or something he worked with
blacks whites and Asian people I know at
a job you know Pike it was called Pike
meadow or something these two meadow
it's cut metal and [ __ ] and weld and all
that [ __ ] so my left hook we were kids
it was three of us only right it would
be for the other kids came in and [ __ ]
everything up we couldn't go nowhere no
more [ __ ] we had three kids I would have
been a college graduate bro I'll have
better teeth ha ha [ __ ] you know I
had a baseball glove with my name on it
I would have been on metal put him at
least uh before I wouldn't know if I
would have met her at a younger age
oh my god crank it up did I was kinda
wish Universal Studios boy - you were -
no they call me bad it was like - man I
was like into everything bro that there
was a car like it was like when I was a
little kid I don't know Jimmy I'm dating
myself a little kids roll six million
dollar man was on a TV ha I got a
Universal Studios he majors in yeah so
when you watch Universal Studios there
was a car you could lift the dog I
remember that oh yeah you could lift
that [ __ ] him and then uh there was also
an episode so we're on TV where I refer
the Wonder Woman or Bionic Woman she was
standing next to a big ass bone all the
clothes I'm moving the incredible
shrinking woman so she was a little lady
Lily Tomlin right so Universal Studios
they had a humongous EV phone ever to
picture its performances call me yeah
man so that the novelty I remember one
other all they had with a regular tour
jaws
Ton Ton my dad was killed with the whole
thing bro that's awesome dude so yeah
man hell yeah I couldn't get a Harry
Potter bro I was a fat ugly guy
transformers is a badass hi to those who
actually broke down were there we were
studying alive for our already a dollar
ten minutes Reuben a delayed for another
15 minutes
so those no moving
- ten minutes then finally on the the
radish shut down the [ __ ] I dropped so
with other Autobots to walk out of their
league you guys had to get up out of
your seats really go I not gonna 4c get
out of a line
oh okay baby broke down before you guys
actually got on it alright so that was
that
yeah do personal scooters cool you guys
do that little thing where they show you
the 3d or like green screen and all that
[ __ ] a little [ __ ] so what we'll do
next time what's the next time I'm gonna
get on a Spanish line goes empty because
they have language it at Universal
Studios you want to be English not too
big a slide you want to do um Spanish
are Muslim or Chinese or Japanese it's a
lot of another line to the sides there's
our recordings are in their language
yeah so I already know the tour how much
you go to a Spanish work will have to
walk that line broke ah dude in the heat
of the day is [ __ ] packed on list
over here drinking more Getman Modelo
michelada the line When in Rome des but
also [ __ ] obvious people bro a
universal studios in which line in all
over I want to tell you my house
potatoes I'm gonna tell you anything man
but you know might think that America is
all white that's funny in Arkansas but
if you go to city wok we took over the
city water effects against blacks Indian
people Asians we took over the Universal
Studios tour there was nothing but brown
faces brawling
you see a couple of Midwestern people
but you know their palette tourists oh
yeah but not really no no I'm no white
American from America from California
we're at this it was on Mexican brulee
we won the Battle of city wok oh those
are fat ass chase bro dressed a little
Harry Potter girls are sweating dog with
the little ones is she walking around
ah my cheeks bro and fat an Asian
Mexican chicks but wearing or the gown
because you put a wild you through
sweater people hundreds wearing bra
sweating you know the crotch was even
more sweaty hard
yeah that's why I keep I keep that okay
I get grossed out I'd like to take the
next level how much they stink I was
about this close lady rubbing all day
she's all foul haha
she's picking food on her mouth if you
know that snatch taste bro I'm gonna
tell you be Hyrule that wand a little
weed seed in there hot dog we got some
spell next Raj in the Sorcerer's crotch
you know I love watching man when I see
like a black nerd bro what's up I'm not
I'm a black nerd like who look cool like
Sony McCullough or car get a handlebar
Hera Hannibal Buress
you know Jerrod Carmichael nothing like
that black looking cooler like an Urkel
no bro fat [ __ ] dumb fat ass [ __ ] it
now what's the name man who can't think
of it that the fat I do for lady Murphy
with that kind of Nordic lumps nor big
dirty ass who's wrong
Lenore's roll like a real nerd that's
already said on MTV bro real nerds not
doers don't get laid dawg I'm not they
have dad's real efficient carpal tunnel
never [ __ ] a Harry Potter gone full
of dandruff huh what else you guys yeah
man yeah brah could get on a [ __ ]
Harry Potter right Brock back off fat
ass big was everyone looking at you yeah
oh really Felipe you're gonna get a ride
nah bro they're for me next time I
change my mind
I cut it out but leave I got answer the
phone call nothing where am i deaf bad
things are on it I got on it
how'd you sit I said good dude you sat
on the freight like this yeah do you
[ __ ] that's what I don't understand I
told you there was some really round
people on it how many clicks did you get
there you go I remember I just remember
[ __ ] to be on the right I was that
lovely at while click
the light turns on but the light turned
on but didn't go did it make the shot
noise huh
you do it a little kid for us your hold
on man yeah but that's what it is all
simulated because you got screams inch
in front of you look badass dog yeah man
so there now I don't know what what what
right it was it took a photo of me I'm
gonna won screaming grow the money the
money they take photo me that ass oh
yeah what else you get on a lot of [ __ ]
deer wasn't your girlfriend her son no
well the first time and then we win a we
went alone that night like a dog style
so it's cool
otherwise I didn't want to go on too
afraid but yeah it was badass dude
[ __ ] what else's address apart to
right oh yeah dude
the only thing I didn't like about that
ride you get [ __ ] wet dog walk with a
big old fat rest ah dude ugh [ __ ] did it
got me the whole side I was like [ __ ]
and was that night dude oh now you can
tell it's [ __ ] you know recycled
water that's just how about dude and
they had a little water park over there
and now Universal Studio and everybody
getting wet in in the front and in the
park all inside bye-bye-bye um tuna real
whatever it's called rhinorrhea yeah I
know where you I know it's a hotel
yeah everybody's you know especially
when you thought yeah crazy huh yeah
that's cool though man
Hubert Universal Studios push each other
um maybe like seven or eight years ago
that was it with your whole family yeah
what my two boys do understand man how
people do it bro
I see I think guys was for kids five
kids walking on Universal Studios and my
dad taking off for our brother hitting
kids on the way home I get that season
cancer was good I could remember what I
ate over there were no the kid nothing
too expensive came home hungry let me
tell you about you have [ __ ] more
than three kids the sky is not the limit
man five dollars in the limit for
everybody
I was hungry bro down with hungry I
would hungry at Chuck E Cheese yeah
that's not the world not even after we
ate I was hungry and no ticket never I
told when follow a great boy over here
he took me and my brother to eject too
I'm Chucky Cheese I told you that and I
didn't know it's a Chucky Cheese that
when people leave their food at the
table I didn't know that they're coming
back uh I'm done later my brother and I
bro we took their pizza which one other
table and ate them all Perkins on back
home and white boy came back on Bella's
family animals produce a Thank You
Rebecca let's go get another slice after
[ __ ] I don't know why people fight
each other at Chuck E Cheese by the
alcohol alcohol dude the only time I've
only been at Chuck E Cheese a couple
times now one time for Philips birthday
I was like probably the second or third
time and other than that not once is the
kids remember I thought it was late oh
you were with me that dad I took your
cheese when I'm full of birthday when I
do from the Avenue shoulder with his son
I think oh my god he was doing his
one-year-old son I guess him and
girlfriend he would might have been like
22 years old he had a big 8 a ve s on
his neck
like a big warning the people daddy
sometime there you go oh my god
we're so fool we have enough today's
episode is sponsored by hollow fresh and
I'm asking about that fat chick at
Universal Studios today's episode is
sponsored by hello fresh a brand new
sponsor go out and support this company
and let them know you listen to the show
hello fresh is the leading meal delivery
kit service each week hello fresh
creates new delicious recipes with
step-by-step instructions designed to
take around 30 minutes for everyone from
the from the novices that means dumb
newbies or rookies to seasoned home
cooks who don't have a lot of time
that's me and I have a lot of time hello
fresh user
the freshest ingredients measured in
exact quantities needed for the recipe
no wasted food no running to a store for
one thing we forgot you put like a
daffodil hello fresh sense centers a box
we chose the vegetarian box and it was
on our porch when we got home
big recyclable box insulated had a cold
pack in turkey powder all fresh had a
big old icebox and works out to less
than $10 a meal
Lisa and I chose the two-person box but
you can order for up to four people just
last night Lisa made the text the text
makes risotto honest answer - [ __ ] or
good because we're vegan she didn't use
the cheese that came with it
she used the vegan cheese instead but it
was so delicious it was good dude every
time I don't know xoto oh yeah it's like
it's like the Italian version of PA oh
it is it is like speedo or welcome papa
welcome poyo it's good it's like dry
cereal but we added our own vegan cheese
and we are it we also added from being
in numb chicken but you can also add
your own chicken or your own cheese but
it comes with cheese already
I could eat ten bowls of this [ __ ] dog
it was good but when I say you the
packages I'm gonna give me one you can
take it home we got it right here man
just don't open it right here cuz
nothing inside so the bill the meals
come like this it is the risotto it
comes like in our box that look like
we're the that it looks like we're the
government cheesy to come up and all the
ingredients are right here had a pepper
leg and a pepper ear corn shallots
another and the garlic and everything is
and everything in a little bag are you
just going to put it together yourself
bro it's good for those of you out there
man shout out to [ __ ] green one
yeah chingu in one he's out there
brought in a lewd way bro yeah it was
good
he lost a lot of weight send me a
picture on snapchat
I know it's arching we're at the I saw
the latter but I poke your buddy and
shirt his pants were falling in [ __ ]
when your hands are falling I mean they
are no more waistline huh
hell no no more but it's gone dojo when
your waist is bigger than your waist
like I even burn no ass all about was to
wear suspenders I'm gonna be laughing
everybody's a little [ __ ] Ivan I've
been Cuellar bro sellin pot Salim bar
man Oh fool the intern for life man so
what'd you do buy Lisa with a good she
said it was good man she gave me the
waiver
hell yeah Jesus often it was easy to
make man how long you been a vegan huh
six years bro I used to be a 300 pounds
numb to 83 pounds a year we want to feel
sad every day how about you get a get
one of those scale and put it on it your
bed man every day you feel fatter a
[ __ ] battle especially every day you
don't exercise you exercise with your um
yeah I go on walks
power walks hello fresh we're still on
Lisa covering here okay okay people hey
does vegan cheese nope
some don't dare cheese doesn't it just
so it crumbles or well there's a brand
called follow your heart and they do um
melt good and there's so many cheese's
now man is another one called cheese
cheese cheese
yeah and they use that in pizza at the
masa masa and I'm Echo Park they make
one of the probably the best Chicago PD
in all of California my life anchovies
is the bomb is women after engineer over
here you ever had Chicago pizza an hour
later was good
never give it to Martha and Nicole Park
you like you like to go to pizza
deep-dish deep-dish nah more of a New
York style all right so this girl
talking about hey well shook when uh
when the total Berkeley came out and
said that out about even looking for
Chicago pizza he's he called it okay he
called it up come on man they got the
casserole pizza there you can serve a
casserole pizza is roll ish yeah I do I
can say that but I do a pizza but not
bad it's heavy I love skin thin pizza
broccoli yeah 80 of them well that's a
difference do you a New York you were
looking for it well that's the
difference at the honorary corners but
that's the difference within being thin
slice you're going to eat more opposed
to having like two or three slices of
some deep dish pizza but have to do also
a little water of New York water is
better than red the bread tastes better
yeah I heard about the water that
there's a no 1 player in LA that have
the water shipped in from New York
I don't bagel right I was in the Louis
bagel I am that's owned by that man huh
we saw a woman who that every King back
to our people at the airport off all
right who has the best pizza in LA we
got to read this [ __ ] every time mr.
Chang
just last night Lisa made text with
risotto
our listeners can get $30 off their
first week of
hello fresh just visit hello fresh calm
and enter fool 30 full 30 also shout out
to the guy who bought the razor from
Dollar Shave Club
oh yeah he put it up on Twitter - thank
you very much big dog thank you bro
if you're looking for some shaving stuff
or hit up on Dollar Shave calm yeah or
if you're looking for a food bro
you single I got a girlfriend did you
cook um not really what movies you get
into this right here yeah hello around
hello fresh everything's changing man
like no go with the times everything's
changing man like even my neighbors
who are senior citizens they're not
shopping no more like the roll people
they're not shopping at the grocery
store no more they're getting their [ __ ]
delivering uh from Amazon milk you too
and I still go to the store cuts down on
time go I know my give me more time to
nap now you go to the store in the heat
of the day dude everybody's [ __ ] there
it's gonna take you [ __ ] a half-hour
to get in half-hour to get out on top of
doing your shopping man and then man if
I do it there's not the case sometimes I
like when you go to like do you get this
richer like you go to the same Barnes
the same Rao's the same EBT store or the
same uh whatever store you get to know
the cashiers manager sometimes you know
what even though you have nothing
against the cashier personally you don't
know him
he never doubt you never he never did
you bad but you know which cashier you
gonna go to now you just avoid some
cashier who just [ __ ] Yap too much one
yeah I agree with that
there's some people just talk too much
other you wanna get the [ __ ] out of
there they want to make it go you don't
make something here oh yeah yeah and
they try to interpret all the things
that you have and what you gonna do with
it like at the bars I go to there's an
old man who there's two people out of
that moment
this one the old man he just annoying
brought in an old man but he could tell
that he wanted to be an actor but time
passing by no just gay I'm not gay he's
not Gabri act gay you know means he's
flamboyant I used to yeah he's and then
he's figure out how to speak every
[ __ ] language just to annoy everybody
homey language god [ __ ] rosetta stone
yeah like about Armenian woman shows up
all in special ChaCha
then at least a little more top - OH -
dogs let me look at me hey guys how you
guys doing and party they just stared
for a long time when ideas I avoid a
mother
no more boy now to the manager now
Ultima walking here he goes on the world
where he's at what's up fool he could be
helping an old lady give birth so stop
and go
Sabu holding the baby and whenever
there's a lot of line in the in the
cashiers he's not doing nothing bro but
he'll open up the other cashier just for
me what's up ooh that glow over there
bro and I put a subscribe I think is
telling everybody went to high school
together I remember the [ __ ] dog
like well yeah yeah yeah rid of all high
school class of 89 yeah swim team II god
damn move big rough a fourth bullet
martín gotta find another Vaughn's dog I
am Babu to Granada Hills haha Tobiah
dad yo yes I'm gonna heels yeah all
cheer on Reseda
living in resi yep oh yeah I live in the
valley
yeah you really right in Granada Hills
would it be neighbor yeah I'm about to
take my street for is hahaha that's
border Delta J Reseda Jason yeah resina
jjwong bro yeah Mission Hills we're just
gonna show up right this coat is still I
can't say that right yeah yeah we were
looking for a place to live in all that
area and Mel Allah [ __ ] love [ __ ]
Transformers over there man
the electrical power yeah Porter Ranch
ok frequency dresser were so full what's
wrong with you chairman which bit up the
latter we talk this is the last time we
talked to instead of Comedy Store what
you know which one he was on everybody
here listening man rather rather be a
lot of editing in this holster here
there was room over here on the Wheels
of Steel while trying to look it up it
only goes up to episode 53 dude so I
know it was a literal key area
kidnapping series right what's your
share of the past get all the
kidnappings here yeah who ever served I
remember we were doing that hell gig we
do a replay that or that Juan Garcia
Chapel [ __ ] that boo ha ha ha ha ha
taking a capital S was trying to move in
with Gracie [ __ ] 4 year old guy with
a roommate that's 40 now yeah I think 35
ah time flight awful oh I don't know how
to do it comedy no nineteen years it's
been a while
I'm saying ha ha ha remember everybody
has a 20-minute set many years oh oh
you're the killer maple for a dog stoner
comedy no 16
oh yeah so we're doing 16 years that's
32 years old
34 Wow start at the Laugh Factory shoot
yourself
ha ha you have the same glasses yeah bro
I don't care
it's all strapped to an egg know when
you please back suburban is b-45 out of
the game do something called Apple
glasses at night he'd be fog dog time to
send a burglary that man whoever is
Shmuel here cuz there are some people
they being at your glasses your [ __ ]
you've been wearing glasses your whole
life and it's one of those fools
I don't matter couldn't I used to hell
about bird we're not wearing glasses at
first beady eyes hey cuz either get the
beanie edges I get a big old tomato eyes
dog [ __ ] looks weird dog now I'm mad
with hunger
when Shevlin things exactly is on bro I
really took a little prairie dog and put
them on the Sun bro you another house
one time it Isaac said you look splendid
without your glasses what's gonna create
a machine play married I think so who is
this guy god damn gonna put him on a
rabbit oh [ __ ] time flies goddamn right
dog wow man imagine man have you been
doing it that long
you must be hitting on the new guys
r16 Apple hates Ana's you imagine we
have the right to hate Oh bro we're
successful yeah but we're just over here
try showing of the masses and [ __ ] he
takes it the wrong way it's like give me
a break dog which other make your
favorite here man you don't get it the
Howard Stern bro you're [ __ ]
beetlejuice on the show yeah oh you know
your [ __ ] Beatles Rubino's you had a
personality dog you beauty would have
been her getting back dog getting famous
and [ __ ] laughing about it dude go
with it this is Walter crying that like
the rhythm of reputation what ripple
yeah exactly like when you bang on me I
don't give a [ __ ] keep it rolling dogs
and run of the show keeps going who
gives a [ __ ] what crying bro I'm [ __ ]
over there [ __ ] putting [ __ ]
bullets in your musket dawg you're never
gonna use wait so is this just one time
or was your multiple time one time one
time you got like that which I invited
my second time and he was too busy bro
oh yeah
he was he was too busy to do a real gig
dog that was a gig you were at with when
we did the show with terms at the ice
house oh yeah yeah I mean we had the one
poster yeah immediately when I was there
he's over there retweeting they tell
people to follow him because it was a
big joke behind huh but he shouldn't get
it they were bagging on a mercy or not
those but you know whatever take it away
or whatever way you want say whatever
you want on social media dawg your voice
will be heard your voice will be heard
man but I know we'll do it out of spite
[ __ ] no we never once did we ever say
he's not funny doll use funny dog but
it's just like whatever fool what I
think is funny
Ella had a rose last night OAD here
[ __ ] her bite me bro you think you're
gonna invite you pool I didn't get
invited [ __ ] Flocka was all happy bro
danger but I'll die before I get there
bro there's a burger and I had Robo tell
us where his wife beater broke the wall
and a bullet in one like Robin eggs
toward your head a Jed
there's a rose right there bro look at
understand why all these guys were
afraid of him bro I think we're gonna
bring it up but really I worked up
Felipe showed up like kindness jokes
kinase a I'm sure even if Willie was on
there he'll be doing kind back Flaco
roasted on the devil is this guy's arm
hey can I open for you ha ha ha
guy comes to me with a cigarette smells
bro huh
I want to skate black-suited a this
guy's the most worn out daughter had
ever seen bro so talking to Flaco bro he
set that out
he got a he got a buzz a lot of [ __ ]
one star on this [ __ ] arm
uber driving yeah lift lift face today
somebody wrote the car smell like weed
now you know I get front dog just carry
me instead of him driving me I drove him
to the hospital
[Laughter]
[Music]
typical driving he'll making me rub his
neck ha
cuz I'm a punk a vice grip god damn fool
talking about putting in work yeah man
so how was your room bro good do you
know [ __ ] going on strong 35 people
showed up and they paid oh oh yeah [ __ ]
yeah dude he had a little consolation
but we had we had that taken care of
Benny mana came through I mean the last
minute yeah cookie hole this week like
cookie hole but we have a cancellation
to this week because cookie is in
Detroit who's supposed to come back
Sunday but I guess her mom 6 which is
taking care of her - she's got a new
album
what's it the track name
so yeah dude she [ __ ] out cancelled
shout out to Bruce Bruce Bruce Bruce so
she go oh yeah we all went on Saturday
dog with Philippe all that is what this
lady man's domain I understand how you
doing your blood well well perform with
just him and subdued for my
um DC I forgot his name a brother and
then yeah dude it was there right before
he went up ski was there [ __ ] cool
dude [ __ ] uh this chillin out
it's a wings had a couple drinks to go
you don't know them in the green room
yeah in the green room in the over there
by the DJ booth whiskey she saw a lot of
shirts oh yeah he does it right there up
against the improv side on the stage
yeah and you know get a shirt get a
picture and I did that way whoever
doesn't hold out oh yeah sold out to the
brim killing in her hilarious that I'm
asking for shut up yeah for example
Latino yeah yeah dawg [ __ ] it was a
bit the same bridge he has a couple
different ones dudes like it's different
than a little like the actor he does
over there was that the later he has to
project and talk slower huh oh yeah that
and then you know he doesn't you know he
did you know fifty minutes over here
like an hour so opposed to the 30 so
yeah yeah that's a bring me a towel yo
what's up yeah I think are mosquitoes
are there right ski what's his real name
ski
I don't we just call miss ski ski I
think he ended up talking to the owner
of some clubs I got booked in Memphis
Tennessee oh [ __ ] yeah well do this what
he was comes from a Bruce yoga [ __ ] yeah
dude
wars are boo man Richard chair man
what's up man what's up baby girlfriend
going man oh it's going pretty good been
together for a year and a half now
thanks again
no no chanita oh thank you sellout
hahahaha
I know huh with the name language AJ I
met her on OkCupid is yeah would be your
first lady I don't know boy in Tijuana
hahahaha my yeah my ex-wife is a from
Tijuana
she don't wanna put a hit on you yeah
that's the way that I get her
citizenship huh uh she left me alone
after she got it yes I'm gonna work in
some way later yeah
the dreamers over that's crazy better
yeah she doesn't have a dreamcatcher
anymore she got rid of it a day yeah I
just thought some girl loved me so much
that she'll put a hit on me and why is
that why she put a hit on you um you
know she Bello she said she didn't put a
hit on me but she has a higher dog she
hired
to follow me around is what she said to
scare you um no well she thought I was
messing around you know so she wanted to
hit was all about yeah and then the guys
kind of figured out what this guy's
making money in Pig wanna let's try to
extort some money or something and
that's that's how that happened back in
the sixth with the sequester of days
that's right that's right it was really
hot back then so Lisa if you really love
Felipe hire some guys to follow him
around with the intention of extorting
money and hurting you he word intent
what's that
all right check it out all right boy uh
yeah feed on yo ass I I lost my dog okay
I had a dog the type of dog that you
love but when you open the gate age its
bolts oh sandy I see bad line yeah and
so one day um we were taking the kids to
school and you know running late sand
sandy took off it's like oh [ __ ] you
know we we don't have time to go get her
so you know we had to just take the kids
at school came back and started looking
for sandy and then I had to go to work
so their mom stayed home and she's gonna
look for the dog and she never found the
dog but somebody else found the dog this
guy named uh Marcelo hahahahahahahahaha
from Chile and he called her and now
they've been together for six years yeah
and we've been divorced for five years
even if even a player man the dog went
to I don't know where the guy found my
dog I don't know blame it on the dog
that's I know see what happened when you
forget to tuck in Yoli that's right
don't get a better answer like what
happened a boy how you change the dog
yoga be a dog catch a dog catch up to
the dog getcha go
that's crazy go you know how long the do
you hurt we got neutered a will you her
go cheat on you I'll break your heart
before no army bro trust me oh I wanted
to be with me but I'm good oh that [ __ ]
is different by being her bro just
getting to get her you touching nobody
he'd be fine but I never had that now
somebody cheats on you breaks your heart
feels good yeah has happened to you all
the time
really naughty what yeah one time I
didn't know how it happened but it
happened oh well I mean I I kind of
blame myself too you know ha ha ha why
why you know I was a dick yeah what were
you dick I don't know Chuck yeah I mean
I see oh lady there wow you know it's
just uh you know we married young you
know so yeah you marry young and you
really don't know what you have who is
gone okay let's go looks good yeah and I
mean I I'm a better man yeah I guess you
could say that yeah you learn from it
you know if you do a brew you look at
the moment you're like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
you know and [ __ ] up ever is but you
know you get over you learn from it it's
like a hug okay I could I could have
done things differently
so you gave a reason to cheat then
doctor what yeah I don't know about all
that man cuz when you actually do the
you know the crime you know it's then
you know then you know you you know it's
on her who cheated to know right uh
illegal to this is all wheel on the side
no there's no need for that
got wheeler no no I did there were some
girls that I thought were cute yeah I am
yeah I remember up go wheeler and that
place a portal to call Parker model not
another daughter play they have
prostituta Mexico they have Adelitas
Adelitas Chicago club what time I I am
got ears we're talking about here on and
I looked up a delete that you see if
anybody on Instagram got crazy uh-huh
and also got a did
a photo of one of the prostitutes oh
really she was hot oh no they are dude I
thought they were all dirty no instead
of thinking about chase like like a
bomba bro with all these great progress
I guess he is hairy legs every fact I
told that one time after was the last
time we did the American comedy club I
went there with Flaco we went to the
Hong Kong Club that's where we're at hi
and we walked over to a Lolita which is
like a couple buildings or in the same
block but next door and uh there was
like two just it was the girls were hot
but there were just too many like high
roller like high-profile dudes there
that he look like you can't [ __ ] around
so just bailed and it was just different
no I think we went there first but um
your dollar was larger at Hong Kong you
know you get a [ __ ] you know fifty
ones it lasts for like five hours Dan
yeah we're there but we're getting ready
to go
[ __ ] no bro [ __ ] alright Flaco
[ __ ] got two hours you can [ __ ] out
of here now you're talking about like
Nauticus or something or what are you
talking about I don't know you know just
like people I don't want to hang out
with then you got a little nervous Italy
yeah I didn't feel safe there I'll be
honest with you but the chicks were
[ __ ] unbelievably hot like playboy
hot like I was kind of tripping off a
damn those tripping that when I saw that
photo and they tell delete that and that
guy wrote something look what he was
probably rolled but it was something
like like that was lady
hahaha lady bro I'll just say her name
was Michelle no it would be Michelle me
Shelly Mika can't wait to see you again
papacito or that I like calm down bro my
dad you know he focused oh that photo
got the rack it's funny cuz one of the
strippers in the Hong Kong Club me and
Flaco editor on Facebook student in
America nosh is elated Rosarito pictures
of her and her dog which is but somebody
making money off this somebody making
money because I'm making tons of money
there dude oh but I hate that line
no you just kind of mess it up huh now
you commute I guess someone were just
right outside of that Club
someone get stabbed or gets beat up or
something bad happens they're gonna [ __ ]
everybody up that what they've all done
well one of the reasons why I kind of
said [ __ ] this place is called the Hong
Kong Club was because they were rolling
a full up on the outside of Anita's
which I think he got out of line I don't
know what he did but they beat it
ass like beat his ass dog not like he
has a chance to fight again it was like
a dead body basically this one's out for
the cab in the Captagon so like man [ __ ]
that let's go Don come home Simone says
it's [ __ ] on over there when there's
the [ __ ] he did bro I don't know for you
can't I don't know food get liberal talk
you mean you're in another country
slow your roll player I read oh god I'm
a cat though I mean we'll just talk I
don't know what happened I'm not asking
any question that's just what we hey you
know what's really good and so now
another thing like a wheeler Kentucky
Fried pooches man have you had that no
that's a genius right huh that's no man
is the chicken necks with chicken necks
yeah boy dick why not chicken eggs Oh
next that's what the question yep of
course all that or is it gizzards nah
they do the chicken necks and it's deep
fried
yeah the deep fried sort of diesel yeah
yeah I mean there's a lot of boning them
but you don't eat the bone it's peaked a
little bit of the meat that's around it
you don't get a lot of meat out of it
but it's really good oh yeah
hey it's like chicken kebab or [ __ ]
that's all more you can get tacos you
know that uh yeah what is the strangest
from you memory about med school
this changes um it's a scene a dish from
Sinaloa and it's like a brain soup oh my
god yeah yeah what kind of sets was like
they're less called brain yeah cow
brains because you have it up huh it's
all cut up and all like little pieces
yeah be chief called oh I think she got
her they say never a taco the sense of
the particles are good yeah talk to the
sauce is good soft me yeah but but the
surgery was kind of good taste is a
little back taste on it a great gamy
taste oh yeah a brain yeah yeah I've had
to me I had a brain from a cow tongue
ears probably cheeks stomach everything
man yeah three bucks has a weird taste
ah or telepathic delicious man yeah but
you just gotta ask him to a killer
daughter Mia or was it gross what's up -
what creeper stripe intestine cut yeah
oh man so larger test I think about the
etiquette Bourdain he was in Rome and
they were eating tribal and they were
free pass huh and it was all able to
our boy old bro the neighbor male a
mexican-style and they put it put
mozzarella they put our marinara sauce
over it they were eating it just like
that man
with bread I thought you will [ __ ]
grow Romans out huh
I thought waiting goes alright cooked it
yeah but I already bought it but when I
saw them when she took it out of a
little Bowl eating it it's too little
white well that's why I never like to
the kid they love the mouth shoe yeah
yeah if you don't clean up Molly T sick
[ __ ] right yeah well that's what it is
there's an amount of [ __ ] that they have
in their intestine so you got to pull
the [ __ ] out of them you gotta yeah
that's a lot of [ __ ] cleaning man a
grip of work my dad a manga yeah y-you
got ammonia and I was so gross Royal
Flush amount oh yeah but you know what
man I never thought about when you cook
it smells good
it's good darling if it's done right
it's [ __ ] bomb I love to because man
and what's up with you going back down
to Mexico like what's your whole
infatuation how'd you get down there
what's up
well yeah I was going to San Diego State
and I had a classmates that were from
Tijuana and I used to hang out with them
and I would go down there drink and eat
tacos and then I noticed there was
apartment for rent next to them so I was
like [ __ ] it I'm gonna rent it and I
rented it and I ended up moving down
there and I was just thinking I'm gonna
learn Spanish now and I would commute
every day to school from Tijuana that's
how I moved to TJ and then after I was
down there and I was like you know doing
homework and [ __ ] and I was like I need
a computer
there was no access to computers back
then you know I mean you went to
internet cafe and their computers were
all [ __ ] up it was really slow so I
thought you know what I'm going to open
up an internet cafe and a couple years
later after I graduated and I became a
teacher I was teaching in San Ysidro I
actually opened the internet cafe in
Tijuana
in the sink ODS in Placer Sun Hawking
popular yeah it was very popular um it
was always full I get over hours
no was in 24 hours until later the first
one was in 24 hours but you know back
then there was none huh there was no
girl kept it was like two and all of you
wanted how good was that
nah they suck [ __ ] yeah and the
computers were really slow so what I did
you know
Korean you know we love technology it's
got to be fast so I did that and then I
got a microwave connection for internet
from a company that was sending the
signal from San Diego into Tijuana so
anyone who had the antenna that was
facing their antennas could get
superfast in in it and that's what
that's how I got fast internet in
Tijuana and it just blew up from there
just blew up I rented the lock on next
to me at another 34 computers in that
one and then I opened one in central
sync with years old I maintain a
novembri yeah I just kind of blew up
from there so it's good [ __ ] mogul
let your mom's killers your wife's
killers contracted you that it happened
around that time also he had it yeah you
know money was coming in and I mean look
I'm not saying you know I mean I did I
was talking to girls you know but not
nothing for her to you know like hire
people found me around you know I mean
nothing that's it you know even if
you're [ __ ] it all nothing worth you
know putting your family in jeopardy so
what do damn dog so during danger yeah I
mean I was in my office two guys came in
wearing sunglasses but all know they're
about the same height and they're like
five six five seven you know not very
tall they were greasy I remember that
very clearly like greasy and sweaty and
Mexicans showed up are you talking jg
domine especially a brain story watch
the mouth he's just a ghetto assassin
over here yeah [ __ ] you or he was sweaty
menudo chick tell me sanim I know fat
balls at that bro just thirty horses
that's what I'm saying that's how they
look you know and they didn't Shane I
mean it
I remember they just looked dirty and
then they were telling me hey we're here
to help you all that all what do you
wanna help me
yeah exactly just like that and I said
oh I don't need any help thank you and
like no you don't understand you know
we're here to help you and you know
first explain it to you should come with
us I know that I'm not going anywhere
with you guys and we went back and forth
a little bit like that for a minute and
then thank God you know a friend of mine
showed up and you know we're going to go
out for lunch that day and so when they
when my friend walked in I just kind of
like sit you know like just be the end
of me you know telling the guy so you
know thanks for coming you know and
Eddie oh yeah we'll see you next time
and so they just kind of went along with
it
you know and they went downstairs and I
called downstairs and they're kind of
hanging out for a little while and then
finally they left you know and and I
told my friend what happened
she's all worried you know who are these
guys and he went downstairs looking for
them up i god that's why I didn't tell
him it when the guy showed up but after
that I was really paranoid like the next
day you closed not next day I'm just a
stayed in San Diego after that signed
everything over to her name that was a
plan right I we got a place in San Diego
and I just I would just go back and
forth and just check out the businesses
never took the same route to or from the
places that I would go to always looking
over my shoulder always had somebody
with me it was like Denzel a man on fire
dog yeah exactly
it's not a it's not a way to live and so
the moral of the story is don't lose
your dog and and their lady okay that's
right yeah be good to your wiseguys all
you guys out there they have wives and
girlfriends like if you will if you were
to kill both of those guys right there
I would you do it no way you could
experience the car but it has to house
owe me I have to kill oh well if you use
the gun you would go to jail because
guns are legal Mexico they're legal
right everybody has them though
everybody has yeah but firearms are
illegal like like in America just some
places just like our good you can't have
a gun unless you're like a government
official or military but to do so the
girls at the stores there isn't ha I've
never seen a gun store no how about
rifles you have a rifle blast
right oh yeah yeah that's different I'll
get all that all military or government
yeah well you have a shotgun yeah a
30-30 rifle I think it depends on what's
in there each Pony see feels different
come true bugs are not my uncles and all
it's a federal local the other like
triple they all have girls bro but they
all go hurt seats we I am there is a
reason for them in heaven sir my uncle
he brought up that gun a full of July
bro
I can be chic workers we even sell birds
actually no one [ __ ] [ __ ] works in a
footsweep at 45 it's 44 Magnum it's our
blasting it goes back into the house
where was this live in LA we're living
on Oak Street
shout out to Wally's liquor store on
Washington sorry about the good shot but
some of the gunshot you heard on that
Street Trinity the first New Year's that
I spent in Guadalajara with my ex's
family we were outside lighting
fireworks and also just here like
machine guns yeah like crazy and you'd
like you here far away you don't think
anything and I'm leaning against a car
and also here's like a hissing whistling
and a bullet comes right through the
hood of the car for right I mean not
even like three feet away from me
everybody back in the house
you know it's bullets or falling huh
yeah they were following anywhere you
know you're supposed to be here Richard
Cheney and that's right that's crazy
good in a mood of the Mexican with Brad
Pitt and James Gandolfini and Jay
Roberts and no Mexicans that movie yeah
having a shootout in the air and there's
a guy that a Doug that was supposed to
protect Brad Pitt a bullet for the top
of his head when he's sitting in the
truck no they come down back to that way
right come on faster you know just as
fast we heard of his TV yeah you hear
this you hear it like like like like
like just like that it's like a hissing
right like just a few seconds back
before it's gonna land yeah man they're
shooting over your head you can hear
them too man I want three on my porch
and the rival neighbor who was blasting
at our
neighborhood and it would rather play
around other yeah and then you can hear
the bullet cloud or roof like you can
hear them right yeah
all that buggy I've never heard those
before life you hear whoops
right just like that yeah you can outrun
that you know hey uh what you hear it
it's coming up it that's it that's final
laughing you would hear yeah yeah before
you if you got hit by a bullet out that
people asking you here cuz I always
thought that when you hear those the the
bullet noise the bull is already here oh
yeah I thought of gunshot ah the gunshot
last right oh yeah
the bullets already gone then the yeah
right I don't know aerodynamics I don't
know if you hear the pop didn't hear
that you get shot right or at the same
time she didn't get your they were cited
in the house their computer whiz over
here cafe chain she still working with
bands yeah I'm working with a kid named
Danielle Gina's from Tijuana
he's a solo artist and we just recorded
his EP and he's actually coming back to
a studio in Glendale not too far from
here and to finish his uh to do the
finishing touches on it so that'll be
coming up pretty soon we ran into
homeboy out there for Duke yeah regular
car oh yeah yeah I got the million
followers on [ __ ] Instagram oh man
he's got millions of views on YouTube
he's he's he's he's big we also uh two
weeks before that we ran into that bad
Latino macho so Nene okay uh yeah yeah
Santa Santa LAX avoid you meet on lax
huh yeah you'll find everybody in like
they were on the way to the East Coast
oh yeah Jersey New York City Connecticut
all that [ __ ] oh yeah I'm not big
everywhere everybody goes big yeah yeah
banda aceh
honda macho and yeah I got banned
aluminous big banana si from
the mantras in L all right Lamont almost
most big bundles are from Sinaloa yeah
that it's a it's a Sinaloa thing you
know the banda and tomorrow
truely's Lizarraga that's at institution
type and right uh yeah I mean where is
the best place to I think is a
recoilless I'm not measure there there
you go that's yeah yeah there's total
Belgian wait so a Korean guy is telling
you [ __ ] Internet you'll be oh ji-ho
about North Korea tell you what oh yeah
the regional Gangnam style north gong
gong sound be like in that Korean
barbecue baby uh [ __ ] butches weeaboo
cheerful ain't bullshittin eat it nah
let's pound nails oops
oh man uh huh would they what the [ __ ]
do they sell them at the store they D
calm and they have a big old foot right
there come on chicken no I'll tell
Filipinos on sale
Tina - bro now what do they use those
for I've never seen it enough super dog
pulls up in a head with a roasted on
flavor stock for the stock yeah the room
yeah that and butters I know Papa I
believe in there yeah but what yeah what
did you eat yes the delicious but that's
a big pot that right it wasn't right now
waffle bone marrow bone marrows
delicious - yeah I've never I've never
had it but I heard it's bomb I heard
like know every Bourdain talks about it
rose bro yeah I started on Instagram
somebody wants to try it somewhere done
over Vegas and it would be brought up
for his plate was just three bones yep
and they had they were all cut in half
and the middle part had like some juicy
fat with meat and they had lightness it
brought it out bro it was it was
sizzling brewing like what here and he
added he added some flips I'm like some
gravy over it and he just [ __ ] got it
and got a spoon or something this look a
lot of put
mouths yeah see Nancy Bourdain showed oh
it's cowboy caviar hey have you tried it
never mash is delicious the first time I
tried it with in Mexico in Guadalajara
must be salty tacos they threaten oh is
what they call it what annoys bone
marrow taco de no nothing we no no
welcome
yo man I think seola you don't want to
buy some bone marrow tacos transplant
yeah I've never had bone marrow - dude
I'm gonna open up a career here in LA
just like the way they have them in
Tijuana because I haven't had tacos in a
late that are anywhere near as good as
two one well yeah you can never compare
them the food in Mexico they're just too
much much more love they're just
different have you ever been at up-close
what's it called a little wanna Kuato
and TJ I suppose oh no I just want to
talk was that an apology - same one it's
the same one everywhere but the tacos
tonight to go to it will run into a
separate area and it's dark that area so
it's another another another do this oh
shoot it's a guy right there plus a
bottle with a dim light yeah a dim light
and those are the best foods in his a
stuff which is the meat on a big arm
spit I do like a big piece of board like
a big big piece of wood uh-huh and he
has all the meat right in his chop oh
yeah yeah they actually use a part of a
tree the trunk
yes that's it to chop the wood the meat
on oh yeah you know that's a good idea
you have an idea man about to get about
that that's not starting it but you know
when you get high - man they have a
[ __ ] I'm a Japanese guy making you
food right there man the [ __ ] rides
was the pinnacle but it makes your eyes
for uniquely sushi Benihana
hey watch any Hannibal they should have
a baby horns they don't own a lady there
are many fun and very koalas bro baby
needs a wireless roar I have a [ __ ]
guy a real target of professional
taquito still in front of your table
cooking everything bro and maybe no
stuck with a pseudonym too
that's how they do that tacos el gordo
you stand in line and guys you know
shaving the meat off the the trombone
but even they're not even as good though
the ones in San Diego there's another
one that anything's good as one a TJ nah
there's a tacos Eduardo they have a like
for in San Diego and two in Las Vegas
and but the original one is from Tijuana
and a son Oreo right yeah all types of
meat
yeah they have everything you know three
Posada Pastore creepers a diversity pers
bûche cabeza I mean they have it all
converse is good you like catch it eh
yeah yeah la cabeza
but there's original style with a you
know little taco but they put that real
piece of welcome all in there right
oh they do yeah yeah I like this guy's
what salvina this guy's a Boudreaux the
guy king chocolate and the guy in Mexico
old-school just like his hands his
fingernails never touches the tortilla
bro I will see him just grab the two Tia
and then like him he'll he'll put the
two T and a paper and grab the meat oh
yeah yeah perfect hinge hinge and then
the the same spoonful of Ockham only and
the sauce I just slapped it
yeah dude let them really [ __ ]
[ __ ] awesome and here at nine over
here ABS nine in aluminum foil yeah they
step razor mysteries that he slept he
pushed through the front slapped
aluminum foil plus three more slab
aluminum foil and wrap them all together
broke into our hot with some [ __ ]
Fanta the ones I love or the past or in
Mexico City one day because they have a
street is just all passed or like 1215
guys just up a store and they all have
Pina on the top of the Trump oh yeah
pineapples out yeah and they all tried
to outdo each other with the pineapple
tricks
they'll slice the pineapple from the top
and make it fall into the 30 on they'll
catch it
have you ever seen that No oh yeah you
feel it yeah where'd you see that oh
really
we're all real tacos no I think I saw it
like an L flaming taco the truck apart
there you have it that's a good shrug
whoo oh yeah I've been done
right at the car wash slaving sugar low
speed is too low speed is by Griffith
Park all right
Leo's tacos oh you guys try that one I
think they probably have the desert pass
Tonelli
mmm I had embattled passport man take a
bath on so what kind of taco truck as
you see you still had no trouble
chocolate Mexico here was missing bro
here that you would do different um just
got ok first everybody here they use
meat that's already pre-cut when it's
wrong yeah and then it cook they cook it
on the plancha yeah I would marinate
beef with the right marinades you know
orange juice lime juice cumin paprika
salt pepper cilantro oregano just keep
it simple and then a little bit appear
and then grill it charcoal charcoal
grill not gas grill and then once it's
ready then you chop the steak up with a
knife like on a trunk oh you know I'm I
would and the meat is juicier more
flavor and you can hold it better and
won't dry up on you so right about that
cool I worked at King Taco for two days
at Dodger Stadium and everything can
prepare all the make human bags and it
already caught up yeah we just put it on
top of a heated not unheated
so I don't know much about cooking meat
because I ate to [ __ ] up all of me that
cook me is best if he cooks when it's
full art without being cut it cooks
better ah oh yeah good when it's cut up
is burning huh well when it's cut up and
it's I don't cook good huh it kind of
brushes it kind of steams because it's
all clustered together and it steams in
the mix and meat kind of chewy and it's
what I like gray yes right but there's
two reasons I would say tacos are better
in Mexico one is it that's a source a
secondly a taquito like the one you're
talking about he's been doing that [ __ ]
for 25-30 years maybe even 40 yeah
where's here so I'm just gonna do it for
a week in Broward they got their son or
what whatnot and they're doing it to
make money which is why business do it
but I think there's a lot of love yeah
yeah no definitely in tortillas I mean
it's just three elements meat tortillas
and salsa I mean that I haven't seen
many people here in LA and also the
tortillas here a process opposed to the
one right right
well there are some people that own a
handmade tortillas that I use my second
you know they won't ground grind up corn
and do it like that
so because once tortillas it makes it
hard enough they [ __ ] hardened up
yeah like here you can they have life
three or four reheats maybe yeah right
yeah down there one time that's it what
about that when you buy our tortillas
from the tortilla maker to Piero and
Mexico when you buy the Dozen
you could eat that's you today oh yeah
thank you too [ __ ] hard bro right
right the bomb is a speciality there's
no had a press press each other on in
the press 40 L get about press yeah
right beat that [ __ ] yeah so that's
that's what I would do different do
Daktari on tacos el chino those our
friend who build it from from they
visited from texas another name anybody
ever done I don't know her name but she
took hit me up where to kind of find
good tacos first time in Atlanta go to
King Taco tried out there I don't know
what to tell you what sue that's great I
know Rena I was trying to giving all
these places she went to a king taco
kids were her favorite taco was chicken
teach other own oh really
teach our own bro man she couldn't turn
a carne asada or something I'll pass
told ya if you ever let each other on
but she turned only consolation you know
think is bad bro you're fat you order a
teacher room burrito which you should
have never ordered there's some meat
there shouldn't be burritos huh right am
I wrong yeah I agree that would be a
burrito like my language delicious
burrito dude I don't know about Buchi
and brain shouldn't be a burrito I know
I know Buchi this was either bro
so yeah that's another weird one that I
would [ __ ] take off the list
yeah I actually have to agree with that
one yeah but I'll pass or burritos BOM
come to supper classic I will never eat
carnitas only read it now but I would
never eat like a [ __ ] um yeah bro
give me a three bus told us yeah it's
another weird one I haven't had that
either
I've never done it best one time I had
to [ __ ] out passport oh that's good oh
yeah everybody right here and listening
to it man [ __ ] Felipe make an order
talk with her
hahaha but tacos are vomiting we're in
LA I am you know huh : fresh sure you
could get a bad taco bro
i'ma say with some bad tacos are at
Bernie's topless restaurant on Eagle
Rock horrible horrible I've never been I
was away bar set up roll ice at the road
ringing [ __ ] that's how bad it was
yo you they were all there were other
tempel-tuttle I like now bro white boi
chavos hardshell was gon be through whoo
Taco Tuesday Mexican taco yeah
Ernie's tacos don't even go there ha ha
ha why not why not bro I do with a big
buck cooking with a hairy chin war so
food we got richer Chan here manifold
about to open Chan
tacos yeah tacos chin Aloha yeah
investor bro carbonize yeah I wonder how
long will it last people like people are
picking out bro yeah I think if they
should bomb dude it'll hit they're
waiting for some mom that hugs house
although have to be on point because if
you eat good talk with bad salsa
yeah II man I've had phony it's like
when you take tacos you by taco
somewhere and then you forget to put
salsa you did it to your house horrible
tacos ha ha ha ha like what is good
talking with Cholula or Tapatio nah
can't do that
but the Tapatio is good but if you put
on tacos you're not Mexican bad you're
Latin America yeah but you're Hispanic
causing panic
Richard share the only cheetah eat more
talk within us you'd like to Andrew
Zimmern New Mexico dog ha ha flautas no
flautas yeah I like that big in Mexico
to America's big is like El Paso you
know with a place called El Paso she
take Rico's tacos
oh brother closing them down finally
what yeah brother the [ __ ] is they
change the cheese yeah last time we were
there there I'm playing about the cheese
because it used to be like government
cheese type now it's like kinda like
real cheese they want the government
cheese well so fool thank you very much
for Richard Chad
as a real Korean gas now I'll go there
without - you are a Gino bro hahahaha
what so you a shout-out to anybody your
tours anything no no no no tours lately
I'm shout out to my kids already hi guys
show you my satin now hey like me now
Hungry Horse or poor people here we yeah
men's coming up yeah man pasta podcast
episode 25 with a zone and shiki Delic
that's out now came out on Wednesday
check out the comedy show on Riverside
Romano's the Council on also I'll check
out Rodrigo I think it was on be real TV
right yeah that's also on being real TV
that you can get on be real TV or you
can get it on a zones page and yeah man
cause we were there he was on tour huh
he was on tour yeah it would be real man
if you ever don't smoke the same he
don't smoke the same as yeah we were
there man be real has a [ __ ] he has a
roach roaches brother marijuana roaches
that I've [ __ ] 12 inches long huh oh
yeah did that one that's not a roach
motel Rochelle had a joint longer than
this longer than this and the tip of the
joint with one of these like that but
the only smoke to that way so it like
12-inch roach oh [ __ ] yeah doc how about
those older lay stores you guys were
telling that one day oh yeah they didn't
know they didn't know that me and I be
real go way back hell yeah Warsaw boo
yeah man be cool